man chad is informing us that there's  been another turn around in the eric  game and now once again jordan  is winning  wow what a trick  what do you think just when it looked  like you know white got his counter play  everything is fine and then this knight  d to e3  and 11 seconds to eric hansen  what was the trick here peter that  happened  well the the trick was actually that  after king e5 knight c4 king d5 not  easily first you can't take f3 because  of knight takes e3 and after king e6  knight d2 and you can't even sacrifice  your  the rook yeah because it runs into look  actually check at the end yeah that's  that's the problem because otherwise you  sacrifice the exchange and you make an  easy draw but here you were not able to  sacrifice so eric is now with luke h1ef  d5 look gc luke h2 fighting for his life  but uh  very hard to imagine saving this  yeah you can